>> MARKS: Hi everyone. Oh, that's cool, the
music kind of stopped and everybody got quiet.
That's great. My name is Mano Marks. I know
a lot of you out here and so this is really
great. It's really great to be here to see
lot of familiar faces and also a lot of new
ones. Now, this is Pamela Fox, here. She has
flown here from Sydney for this so; we are
really, really privileged to have this. So
this is our--our talk is, What You Don't Know
About GeoAPIs Can't Hurt You. And really it's
a grab bag session, right? Were--were going
to show you a lot of really cool stuff. Some
of it new, some of it has been around for
a little while, but not a lot of people are
using yet, or we just think is really, really
kind of cool. So we're going to go through
it. I'm about halfway through, we're going
to switch computers and at that point we will
take a couple of questions and then we'll
have questions at the end. I'm not going to
do--if you miss any of my preventions usually,
I like to have a lot more sort of give and
take this format, probably not, not the best
for that. So, anyway, I'm going to go ahead
and get started. All right. So, the World
of GeoAPIs. So, you know, we've got--we've
got a ton of APIs here at Google. We've got
Mapplets, the JavaScript Maps APIs, Maps API
for Flash, Panoramio, Maps Data API, Static
Maps, KML, Earth API, and SketchUP API. And
I'm sure we're forgetting some like visualization
stuff and there's a bunch of other things.
And we're not obviously going to cover every
piece of that. Here otherwise, it would just
be one slide per, per thing. What I'm going
to do, I'm going to talk mostly about Earth
and SketchUp related things. And, so, I've
got--I'm going to talk about Google Earth
Touring and the HTML support and I'm going
to talk a little bit about SketchUp and then
we're going to switch over to, to Pamela.
Okay. So, how many of you played around with
Google Earth 5.0? All right. So, then you
probably know that we added Touring support.
A Touring got out something that that developers
have been asking for, for quite sometime which
was much more complete control over the camera
experience. And also added in a couple other
interesting things like, like control over
the time slider, control over, control over
sound and the ability to do--well, there's
a bunch of things here; move the camera, move
the, move models, animate polygons, change
where your placemarks are and show the new
historical imagery that we have in, in Google
Earth which allows you to look back in time
at different, at different satellite imagery.
So, this your, your basic Tour, here. You
see it's got a Tour element. I'm little hampered
by this because usually I jumped up and down
and point of things and I can't quite do that
here. It's got your tour elements, playlist
which is just, you know, play all the points
that are--the things that are going to happen.
And then a FlyTo which shows you a camera
which has, you know, all the things that normally
associate with camera. So, what this does
is it flies you to this particular location
when the tour is loaded. So there's something
you may notice here, you'll see there's a
prefix on some of these elements, the gx prefix.
This is part of the extension name space,
the Google extension name space to KML. If
I had a full tour here which I might have
later, you'd see the actual name space declaration.
So this is part of the KML's standard process
like, the Open Geospatial Consortium which
adopted KML as a, as a standard last year,
built in an extension mechanism which allows
people to innovate within KML 2.2. And, and
add in things that are, that are interesting
for their application and that they hope will
eventually become part of the KML standard.
So that's what we've done. We're--we're trying,
we're innovating and trying to show you new
and fun things. Okay. So, here's a, here's
the sound queue. Pamela wanted me to make
this actually much bigger, but I just wanted
to show how easy it was to add sounds by having
a lot of wide space around it. Three lines,
you know, two el--one element in a child,
put in a sound queue, it plays that when,
when that part of the tour is triggered. Here's
how you change the imagery, you'll see here,
you've got the camera just like we have before,
the FlyTo, but I added in a timestamp. And
what that does is it tells Earth when this
thing takes place so that it can then go through
and change the imagery to the historical imagery
to that, to whatever most matches that timestamp.
I'm going to give a little demo of touring
later that will show you a little bit more
about these things. And here's quickly how
you move a model that uses updates. So many
of--how many of you would consider yourself
KML developers? Okay, that's, that's more
than usual for Google I/O. How many of you
have actually played around with the update
tags before? All right that's good. Okay.
So, that's a good number. Update is one of
those things that's kind of hard to get right
and it's basically how do you add a little
bit of dynamism to a scripting language--to
a scripting dynamism rather to a declarative
language. And it basically allows you to do
incremental updates, changes, deletions, additions
to your, to whatever place marks have already
been loaded. Well, we've adopted that also
for, for touring and you'll see that all,
that all the standard KML names base except
for the animated update and the duration.
And this basically just allows you to change
the position of a 3D model. So no more do
you have to create multiple model elements
with lots of timestamps at slightly different
locations to achieve an animation effect.
What you get instead is changing the location
this way, so. Okay. So we can add it very
easily into, into the Google Earth API. So,
you can load a tour using the Earth Browser
Plug-in. And you'll see here some very simple
JavaScript. You do FetchKML, check and see
if it's actually a KMl object and then it
appends--append the KML object to your DOM
and then you walk through and you look for
KML tours end and add in. This is based on
Romeo Nurik's touring samples which I'm going
to show you in just a minute. So, that's--there's
a page on earth.google.com--one thing I don't
like about Chrome is it graze out the depth
in the URL, but put that URL into the slides
so that'd be available later. These are--these
are basic tours and this is where we'll get--if
we can have the sound turned on, I'll play
you the Jimmy Buffet Tour, it's already actually
starting. So, Jimmy Buffet is a fan of Google
Earth and he helped with our launch. And you'll
see here the nice, one of the nice fun features
is, I think, yes, we're going to actually
go underwater right now. So, those of you
who haven't played yet with the Google Earth
5.0, ocean feature is you can actually go
under the water and see what's happening there.
Okay. And I'm going to next show you another
interesting one. This will still require some
sound. This is...
>> Historical imagery dating back to the early
1960's tells a story of change. Lake Chad
was once the sixth largest lake in the world.
Persistent droughts and increased diversion
of water for irrigation have reduced it to
roughly one tent its size forty years ago.
>> MARKS: So, in the past, what you--to achieve
this kind of effects--I'm sorry, if you want
to see more of this is--these are all in the
website. And to achieve his kind of effect
you would have had to get Google Earth, create
the KML's around it, play through, do a screen
capture using either movie maker which is
part of Google Earth Pro or some other screen
capture software. And then scrip through record
the, record it using a recording and using
microphone as a separate recording of the
audio and then just--and then sink them up
together. And it was, it would have been a
lot more cumbersome experience. And now, instead
of that, instead of watching what looks actually
to me like a video, you're actually watching
Google Earth in action here. So play this
tour, continue playing the tour, will see
it, it makes changes and I can actually move
around within the environment there in ways
in which the original tour author may not
have intended but that's okay because your--the
user, in your own control. So I think touring
is one of the most exciting aspects of the
Google Earth 5.0 launch and also the fact
that we can incorporate it now within the
Google Earth Plug-in and load them using the
Earth API it just--it gives you the tremendous
amount of power. Okay. So I wanted to talk
to you, in--in the latest version of Google
Earth, we added HTML support. So what that
means is--what that means is you basically
can run a browser within your description
bullets. It's not, it's not a hundred percent,
it's not full, it's very close to that and
the documentation it tells you where the little
bits of limitations are. One of the key and
the key points of limitations is you can't
do cookies. So not yet do we allow advertising
using, using Google ads, but I think you can
see where this is going. But you get Java
Script support. You get iFrames. You can have
a full rich experience within your description
balloon, within Google Earth 5.0. And we started
supporting--doing limited support for HTML
5. And you know, we talk about--we've talk
about that a lot in this conference so you
can see that where we're going to go with
that is probably is much more complete HTML
5 support. Right now, we, we use QtWebKit
4.5 and that's--and so you can look and see
what that supports and that's what we support
on the PC. I'm not sure--I forget the backend
whether we're using the HTML 5, but then actually
we have a video and audio support within the
description balloon just using the tags from
HTML 5. Okay, so here all I have is--show
example and Pamela looked at me and just said,
"Really? That's just what you wanted to do?"
I always find it kind of cumbersome to put
like a full range of KML in, into a slide.
Slides are messy--I don't--they're like this
data sink and I have, I have a little bit
of a problem having to actually use them 'cause
I like Google Earth as, as my presentation
platform. But I know people like them so--anyway,
but I much prefer text set. So you'll see
here I've got KML and this is where I'd want
to jump up and points the name space. You'll
see right--let's see if I can just highlight
it right here. Let's see here, this line is
the extension name space for, for Google Earth.
Google Earth 5.0 using our extension features.
And you'll see in here that I've created a
fairly simple form. So you got a place mark
with a name and a description and within that
I've got my HTML and you'll see form gives
a method that gets an action which is just
something that's running on a local host.
And it just--this is very simple, it'll just
ask you to input a name and what, what it
does on the back end is it puts that name
into a MySQL database. So I'm going to actually
show you this in action--it's not exciting
obviously, but I think it's exciting for what
it can actually, it can actually do. You'll
see here, form in balloon. And then name,
I'm going to put name Pamela because I put
in Mano before and I submit. And you'll see--actually,
it takes me to the next page within the description
balloon and so--and it gives me back, you
know, gives me back an HTML page. That's all
just running off my local host 'cause, you
know, when I'm presenting at conference I'd
never want to run things off the Web if I
can help it. Okay, so that's, that's a fairly
simple example there. I wanted to show you
another one. This is, this just takes the
basic Google Maps API sample. I kind of love
this sort of--I know I love things that are
kind of meta and putting a map inside the
description balloon that runs in Google Earth.
Fairly, fairly simple but just takes the standard
map--basic map sample. I'll load this up and
I get a map, a slippy map within a balloon
in Google Earth. Now, for those of you who
struggled through Earth, you know, up to 4.2,
4.3 and had to, you know, struggle within
the restrictions of rich text with no dynamic
forms involved, I think that at that point--at
this point, you might be really excited to
see the range of support that we have. Okay.
And I think given the amount of time, I'm
going to move on to the HTML5 supports--here
I am flipping between my browsers. Okay. So--oh,
just a quick note on the limitations. The
full HTML support is not, not yet available
in maps. So if you'll load a KML file into
Google maps, you will, you will--it'll skip
out all the JavaScript and all that. And we
have some differences in a way it's implemented
in the Earth Plug-in. You can talk to myself
or Romeo about that more later at office hours.
And those are--those issues--both maps and
the Earth Plug-in is done for reasons of security.
So I wanted to quickly show you an HTML5 sample.
Okay. So what I've done here is I've created
a Webpage HTML5 test. You'll see in here,
it's got a function, draw Canvas. It's--this
is just--to be honest a sample I took off
the Web, somebody was, was demonstrating capabilities
of Canvas. It just draws a yellow box inside
Canvas elements and that's it. And then it'll
say, "Your browser does not support the Canvas
tag," if in fact, it does not. And we can
then load this up--so I created that Webpage
and then I load it using an iFrame on, on--in
the actual KML and it will show some of the,
the tags that we have here. So you'll see
there through the yellow box. It gives you
a little, you know, a little statement as
to what, what browsers support it. You'll
see here, sort of--I think it's a little idiosyncratic
so far what QtWebKit is supporting. They decided
to support the dialogue tag, so dialogue basically
takes a bunch of form--of things that you
put in in dialogue format and then creates
a default dialogue. So I can show you what
that looks like in the HTML. That's this part
right here. So this, it creates a dialogue
style for you. And--so this is one of the
new HTML5 tags and I'm kind of curious why
they choose to implement that instead of say,
video but it's, it's probably 'cause it was
fairly easy to do and video is a little bit
harder. So that's, that's where we are with
that. And as I said if you, if you loaded
this on to a Mac, you'd have some--you'd have
audio support directly in the description
balloon and video as well. Okay. So the next
thing I want to mention is the Sketchup API.
This will actually be the last thing before,
before I switch over to Pamela and she'll
be talking about 2D maps. And you can see
her getting all excited there. And so Google
Sketchup runs a--has a Ruby API, so basically,
it allows you to do really interesting things
within sketchup like move models around, attach
metadata to them, change their shape, change
their sizes and all that sort of thing--that's
sort of fun goodness. I don't have time to
go too deeply into, into what it can do but
I--instead I want to show you a demo. And
the demo that I'm going to show you is SketchyPhysics
and this is available for free. You can download
this online. It does some really fun stuff--it
basically is a physics engine within Google
Sketchup. And if I played play right here,
you'll see these things dropped and kind of
fall around but even more fun, I can pick
it up and move it around, I can--it'll bash
into things. I don't know. That's my--that's
what I--I just spend time go--you know, moving
things around and bashing them into things
'cause maybe I didn't get to do enough of
that when I was a child, I don't know. And
this--so that I think is a really fun, fun
start. This is even more fun I think. This
is--shows doing rag-doll Physics within Google
Sketchup and so far, you know, handsfree here,
you'll just see it. It's--it flopping about
in this rag-doll fashion and then I can pick
it up and drag it around and do all sorts
of fun, interesting stuff for this. So, you
know, aside from all the--you know, the fun
that I can show you with bashing things around,
people are using this for really serious applications
basically for doing data presentation, of
things like molecular physics and, you know,
to show car crashes and lots of other interesting
things that's--that are really meaningful
but you all are developers, I want to show
you the fun stuff, right? Okay. So I think
I am done. I'm going to switch over to Pamela
and while we're doing that switch over, we
could have some--if there are any questions
on anything we talked about or going to talk
about, there's some microphones up there.
No questions? Ah, Mike. I can always count
on Mike. Yes.
>> MIKE: Hey, Mano, it doesn't seem like the--when
I--the JavaScript works in a KML file in the
balloon but if I try to load it from the Earth
API and if I got JavaScript in it there, it
doesn't seem to go through, is that...
>> MARKS: Yes. That's--we're still working
out some of the security things on that. And
you can talk to Romeo and I at office hours
about some of the details on that.
>> MIKE: Okay, later.
>> MARKS: And we do hope to have a full HTML
support within the description balloons and
the Plug-in. [INDISTINCT] like--I think I
just announced something, I don't know. Van?
>> VAN: Could you just repeat the office hours?
I was getting...
>> MARKS: Oh, we--I think they're on the office
hours list on your card but I think we'll
be doing 2:00 and 3:00 o'clock, so KML and
your API. And there's stuff going--there's
people there are all day so even if we're
not there. Any other questions? No? Pamela,
are you about ready?
>> FOX: Yeah.
>> MARKS: Excellent. I'll put this down so
they can see you.
>> FOX: Sweet. All right. Do you guys all
remember this? All right, sweet. Good. All
right, so enough of that boring 3D flashy
stuff. Let's talk about 2D maps APIs 'cause
that's where it's at; 3D is too hard to use.
You have to use multiple fingers. It's too
hard. Everything I do in life I have to do
while I'm eating food, so I can't possibly
use Earth while I'm also eating food. So you
should see my keyboard, it's covered in lunch
and alcohol and disgusting things. All right,
I'm going to start with some old stuff, starting
going way back with driving directions which
we had to launch--I think like the 2nd month
that I was an official employee, like two
years ago. So most of you, you know, probably
know we have driving directions in pretty
standard--you know, you can load from here
to there. You can also load up to 25 different
waypoints if you want to do it, you know,
massive road trip. We added the ability to
avoid highways since I hate highways. We added
the ability to walk since I can't actually
drive. And so once we've catered everything
that I need, we have a pretty nice API. And
there's some stuff that people have done that
I just want to point out. It's kind of different
uses of the directions API. So first of all,
you guys know on Google Maps there's draggable
driving directions and people really love
this 'cause they can customize their route.
We didn't offer this natively in the API,
but people figured out that really you can
just do it yourself. And so here we go, I
made my start and end. And so this is purely
just using the API. So really you can get
the same experience that you get with Google
Maps with using API and you can use this sample
code for your own app. Another thing, this
is really cool demo here from one of our gurus.
So let's say that I'm doing a massive rode
trip and I am obsessed. Actually, I'm really
obsessed with Taco Bell right now. So I've
been in Australia for the last six months
and Australia is fantastic and has wonderful
kangaroo meat but they have no Taco Bell.
So I have like a massive craving for Taco
Bell right now. It's the best burritos in
the world. So let's see. So I can do a driving
directions route here and then this demo queries
against this guy server to see what Taco Bells
are along that route. And I can say, you know,
I want it within ten miles or more. I'm not
willing to really go that far so I'd probably
do less. Let's say there's not really enough
Taco Bell so I'm going to open myself up and
also go for some McDonald's and some Burger
King's. And now you see that there so many
results that it has chosen to cluster them.
So this is a really nice thing to do. And
clustering is like a new hot thing this year.
So here, he's using some cluster markers and
say, "All right. So there's 61 results there."
I can zoom in and there the clusters break
out and I can actually see the individual
McDonald's and Taco Bell. So now on my road
trip I'm going to be all set with, you know,
ridiculous junk food that I get to eat. But
it's a very, this is a very good experience
for the user to actually see things POIs along
the route that they're planning. All right.
Another thing here along the lines of a road
trip, let's say you've got six different places
you want to hit up and you want to figure
out the best way to head up those places.
So this is a classic problem in computer science
is the traveling-salesman problem, right?
Now the cool thing is you can actually kind
of solve this in JavaScript. I know it's like
OpenMP, it's really hard and stuff like that.
But if you're going to do less than--assuming
you have less than like 23 places to go to,
it's actually reasonable to solve this in
JavaScript with the help of our directions
API? So let's say I've got these six places
and then I'm going to say, all right, calculate
the fastest roundtrip. It goes and tries a
couple of things and then finds the correct
results from here. So I'm pretty impressed
by the fact that this is so fast and feasible
purely in the client. And this was written
by a developer which we later hired. So if
you can solve OpenMP things in JavaScript,
we'll hire you. Yes. So here we have standard
driving directions and I wanted them to be
printable 'cause people often want to print
their directions. So I'm using the Static
Maps API, which we offered last year. And
really just showing, here's the whole route,
here's the start, and here's the end. So that's
something else to do with your directions.
Let's make them so they work better when printed
or maybe from a mobile device. So the Static
Maps API does support markers and poly lines
and labelings. So for the most part up to
a certain number of vertices you will able
to do directions in it as well. All right.
So that's directions. So hopefully I've shown
you that there's something different you could
be doing with the directions on your site.
Or if you don't have directions at all yet,
you should certainly integrate them. So it's
good to actually know how to get places. I
usually just wander around and ask homeless
people but that doesn't work out so well.
So something else that we did this last year
was we came up with the new terms of use.
And some of the parts of the new terms were
happy for people and some parts--other people
didn't like as much but I'll talk about the
happy part. So one thing that we didn't enable
before that we now enable is actually using
the Maps API for desktop applications and
we enable this because we specifically wanted
to encourage people creating AIR Applications.
Anyone here use developed in AIR? And does
anyone use TweetDeck? Yeah. So that's one
of the more popular AIR apps. But basically
AIR is a plug-in or a run-time that works
with both Flash and JavaScript and Adobe created
it 'cause they wanted to enable rich Internet
applications on the desktop, so having the
capabilities of the desktop like clipboard
and dragging and dropping from the desktop
and doing local storage and offline and all
that kind of things that you expect from a
desktop application. So we wanted to make
it so that people could create map applications
for the desktop. And I'll show you actually
from my flex folder, one of those. So here's
our ActionScript API and I'm going to use
the clipboard, so I have this little demo
here, which is a map. Oh, I'll just paste
it in here. So what is does is it takes something
from the clipboard. So let's say that this
is in my clipboard, San Francisco. I don't
think it really loaded. Let me reload that
one. So I'm actually building it from here
'cause I'm not assigned a publisher so it's
not available online. All right. So here's
my map. Now I can just control V and what
that did was it grabbed from the clipboard
and it sent it to the geocoder and then created
a point where it thought that address was.
There's other demos that, you know, read in
the CSV from the desktop or update, do a little
Flickr updates and notify you in the panel
when there's new Flickr photo in the screen
that you're listening to. So that's the kind
of things that you can do with desktop map
applications. All right. So reverse geocoding,
we just have four geocoding in that demo.
Now we will reverse geocoding. So reverse
geocoding is an opposite of forward; so instead
of doing from address to latitude/longitude,
you go from latitude/longitude to an address.
Now the thing is you can also go to multiple
addresses. So usually, when you reverse geocode
there's lots of different things that that
point might represent. It might represent
a street address. It might represent a state.
It might represent a park, a nearby POI. So
the cool thing about reverse geocoding is
that you can use it for so many different
things. It's not really straightforward as
normal geocoding. So there's a couple of different
examples here. So we can look at the standard
example, which is just, you know, you click
on the map and here, that's the address of
the things that point us. And you can use
this if you're doing a tool to let people
create maps, this is a good thing to use because
usually when you're creating a map-making
tool, you want to give them a couple of options
like one, if they already know the address,
they can enter their address, you geocode
it, maybe let them drag the marker around.
If they don't know the address but they geographically
know where it is on the map, then you give
them a little marker tool and let them click
on the map. So here, this is just reverse
geocoding as I click. So this is great because
I can build up all these addresses just by
clicking on the map. So here's a game that
I created based on the reverse geocoder. So
what this does is it randomly queries for
a point in the viewport and gets the address
for it and then quizzes you on it. So here
we have South Dakota. I don't really know
anything about America. Oh, I'm doing good.
N.D. Oh, North Dakota. L.A., it's Los Angeles,
is it? Nevada, Nevada. Unorganized. There's
a city called unorganized. That's amazing.
I feel like they don't have a very good reputation.
Kentucky. I don't remember if there's a timer
on this game. Yeah, yeah, there is, okay.
Missouri, Louisiana, Idaho. Awesome. So this
is cool 'cause I can just generate all these
addresses without, you know, me having to
build up this database myself. And if I was
going to build it myself, it would not look
like this 'cause I really don't know that
South Dakota is a state. All right. Let's
see and there's one more--there's also--there's
a cool site and there's a couple sites like
this called MeetWays. So this is to help you
meet your friends halfway. So actually you'll
put in the start point and you'll put in their
point and then it will figure out geographically
what point is in the middle and then it will
reverse geocode that and then find other information
about that place. And here's something cool
is a control that we added to the API after
we release the reverse geocoder. And what
that does is just puts a little thing at the
top that says what the viewport is that you're
currently looking at. So it's nice 'cause
you can just go around and kind of learn;
Orange, Morris, New Jersey, Bucks. So it's
good just to see what kind of random city
names that we have in the world. All right.
So there's something else that you can do
which is becoming more frequent lately is
actually tell the user where they are when
they're looking at that map. So this is nice
'cause when you go to a map site, there's
usually some default viewport that that company
picks or that website picks when you go to
it. And it's really annoying 'cause usually
you have to go in putting your address and
say, "No, no. This is actually where I am."
And that takes you extra time every time you
go to the site. Like, when I'm in Australia,
I go to maps@google.com 'cause I always go
to everything at dot com and it's always showing
me the United States and then I'm like, "It's
hard, why do I want to see United States,
I'm not in United States. Show me where I
am." So unfortunately Google Maps doesn't
do that yet but you guys can all do it for
your applications. So you can use this client
location API and it will just use the IP of
the user to get a rough guess of where that
user is, so it will tell you the latitude
and the longitude, the city, the state, the
county, and then you can roughly send to the
viewport around that area so that the user
doesn't have to do as much work to get to
what they're interested in on your site. And
one of my favorite examples of that is a site
that has unfortunately been taken down. I
don't know why. It's called HookUpMaps and
it was a Craigslist exotic services' Mashups.
And it's fantastic because as soon as you
go to it, it would show you everything in
the local area, right? So you can get--you
got a popsicle? Sorry. So it would show you,
you know, what you need. And the great thing
is when I visited it 'cause I originally used
this example in China, when I visited in China,
it immediately told me that it had no data
for China 'cause apparently China doesn't
like exotic services. I don't know. And it
would tell me, "Look, this is where we do
have the data and you can go and choose that
region and go there." And so this was fantastic
user experience for me 'cause I didn't have
to like keep searching to try and figure out
if there's any data for my region, I knew
instantly. So it's an amazing site and it
even had little heart icons, because that's
what exotic means. And, what unfortunately
it's down now, so we have to petition to get
it back up. All right, so do you guys all
like money?
>> MALE: Yeah.
>> FOX: Yeah, me neither, that's fine. So
some people do, so we'll talk about it anyway.
So one thing that--actually, you know, John
was--has been asking this last--he ask originally
like two years ago when we launched directions,
like, when are you going to make it easier
to monetize the API and have really good AdSense
for the API? So this year we actually announced
two different new ways of monetizing the API.
So one of them is with the Google bar. So
Google bar is basically a little search box,
you can put on your map, it will turn your
logo into shiny search box and then people
can search for local businesses, and they
can search for addresses using that. And we
added AdSense to it so that you can go and
actually supply your AdSense publisher ID,
and when some people do a search, you'll get
a result and then you can get money if they
click on that result. So I'll show you that.
So here, I've searched for [INDISTINCT] in
San Francisco. Presumably I got tired of Taco
Bell. And you can see there's an ad up there
and I can click on the ad and then the guys
who made this website will make money of off
that. So this is basically AdSense for search.
Now, we just launched something even more
recently, called the maps ad unit, and John
actually was our trusted tester of this, he
was the--pretty much the sole trusted tester,
but he's a really good tester, so thank you.
And, so we'll go and look at it on his site.
You have a 100 percent since they're harder
to see. So what this does, is that it puts
a little ad blank on the map and you can have
one or two ads, and it will actually update
that ad block with relevant ads whenever the
user moves a view port. So we have some magic
secret sauce, whatever, to try and figure
out what the best ads are for a particular
viewport and then we'll update it as it goes
along. So right now I'm in Los Angeles and
then best ad here Ruth's Chris Steak House,
because everyone knows that's the best steak
in Los Angeles, and anyone going to Los Angeles
would want to go there. So it does a pretty
good job at guessing what will be good, clickable
ads for that view port, and we've seen really
good results with it so far, and hopefully
you guys try it out and let us know how it
works for you. You hear that, I didn't say
anything, is that it? So yeah, so there we
go and hopefully next year we'll have more
stats about that. So if you guys have more
questions about monetization of the site and
about the stuff we just showed, there's actually
office hours for maps monetization going on
right now from one to two. So you can leave
now and go ask if you're just really, really
curious or just wait 'til after the talk and
you can head to the office hours, I think
they're just way down there and talk to Mike
Pegg from Google Maps Mania. All right. So
this is something really cool. I haven't talk
about the Flash API much yet, with the Flash
API something we launch a year ago and it's
actually really cool because there's some
stuff you can do in Flash that you simply
can't do in JavaScript. So when I talk about
one of those things that we've been seeing
a lot of in the last few weeks, so this is
re-coloring the tiles and you can do this
in Flash because of how easy it is to apply
transforms to anything in Flash. So here's
this demo here and you can see--I can go and
change this stuff here. I'll make it--no,
it's not very pretty. All right, so here we
go. Now I've got a pink map, this is obviously
really pink. So it's something I should mention
is that you can do this re-coloring but you
do have to send us some email and let us know
what the re-coloring looks like so we can
approve it. Because we don't actually want
anyone making maps that are this pink because
it simply a bad experience for the users out
there, right, and we want to encourage good
user experience. So this pink is bad, right,
but they're definitely some things you can
do that are really good. So let me show you
some of those. So here's an example, this
is a--an interactive slide show of people--900
people in Japan wearing a parka. I don't know,
it's somewhat addictive to watch. But you
can see the map down there, they've really
kind of desiderated and gave a bit of a blue
tint. So that the things that stand out are--are
the icons and it's a nice visual effect for
what they're trying to achieve here. So more
practical example is here, this is for routes
and other things that I can't read of German.
And you see, they've basically, they've grayed
out the tiles behind so that the routes really
stand out on top. And so then I can go and
plan my little trip here. And I think, personally
I think this looks really, really slick. Yeah,
so those are the ones wanted to show. This
is what the code looks like, you're just creating
a color matrix filter and then applying that
to the map. And one other example of how you
can use it is somebody uses it so that when
the map is loading they actually gray out
the map, so that people kind of don't pay
attention to the map because it's a side part
of their site. And then they only re-color
the map once the map has entirely loaded in.
So that--that was a really nice visual effect
as well. All right, and so now let's talk
about something that we haven't actually release
yet, and that's 3D Flash. So let me just show
you what this looks like. All right, so here's
a standard map in Flash, right? Now we decided
to see what would happen if we made it 3D,
and then we made a new control, looks about
like Earth. And now, so we can pan and zoom,
so this isn't full 3D with a terrain, right.
But if you want full 3D with a terrain, you
should go to the Earth API and use all their
fancy shiny things. But this is a--what we
call a 3D perspective, so we can go and add
stuff to it and then we go zoom in here. It's
pretty cool because this stuff actually like
stands up, you can see as I move, and you
can see the shadows lengthening as if they're
in 3D. And we put on a little info window,
here we go. So it's pretty nifty and we managed
to do this both in Flash 9 and 10. So Flash
ten actually has Native 3D so it wasn't too
difficult to do it there. Well, too difficult--the
engineer is here and he doesn't really think
that was the accurate description. But in
Flash nine, we kind of had to create our own
technique for doing it and you can talk with
Mike if you're curious about the crazy math
that he employed to do that. But for you as
a developer it's really, really easy to use,
all you have to do is say that you want this
perspective view of your map and if you want
to let them, actually, navigate around, you
can go and add that new 3D navigation control
to it. And I don't really know how people
are going to use it, we just kind of thought
it would be a really cool thing, and we'll
put it out there and hopefully you see some
different uses of it because it's--it's kind
of--it's in between this 2D and this 3D thing,
so there should be some things that it'll
be good for that maybe the Earth is over [INDISTINCT]
for but the 2D isn't quite good enough for.
So that would be pretty interesting and we're
going to release it--when Mike?
>> MIKE: I am thinking it would be...
>> FOX: Yeah, tomorrow? Okay great, thanks.
All right. So that was basically our grab
bag of things with the GeoAPIs, I mean the
point is, there's a lot of APIs out there,
and when you're making this slide, I kept
forgetting about other ones that I hadn't
added to it yet. And there's a lot of different
features that this--this APIs have and a lot
of different ways you can use them. And so
hopefully you guys will take a little bit
from this talk and integrate it into your
apps. For those of you that are, are already
Geo developers, we are launching today, I
guess, this developer qualification program.
And this is because for a long time there's
been a lot of Geo developers that were really
strongly qualified and we would get request
for developers and say, "Well yeah, you can
go and post it in the forum." And there's
a couple of people we know. But we had no
formal way of recognizing those qualified
developers and of recommending them and pointing
people to, you know, like an official list
of qualified developers. So we've done this
developer qualification program and what you
can do is, you can sign up and get qualified,
and you prove yourself by doing a test, you
guys, you know, if you miss Uni, university,
you do references, right, so people you've
worked with, you do community persuasions.
So, if you're very active in the forums, your
community persuasion will help you, and, I
think, one other aspect. So using all that
information about you combined, we use that
to decide, "Okay, this person is qualified,
let's badge them and, you know, put them in
our gallery of qualified developers." So for
those of you that are Geo developers and maybe
our freelancers or somebody that wants to
say, "Hey, I'm available," then
you should get certified, get qualified and
you'll get a badge and you'll get in the gallery,
and then we'll get to recommend you to everyone.
And you can get a shirt too or a sticker.
Yey! So that's it and now we have time for
questions. So if you have questions, you can
come up to the mike.
>> MARKS: All right.
>> We're also looking--we have questions on
moderator too, right?
>> FOX: Oh yeah, maybe.
>> MARKS: How do we get there?
>> Okay. I've got a question on reverse Geo
coding.
>> FOX: Yeah.
>> What happens to the IP and copyright when
you do the reverse Geo coding?
>> MARKS: IP and copyrights?
>> Yeah.
>> FOX: Of the data?
>> Yeah, in the data that you get, you know,
when you put your own data base, what are
the rights and the restrictions are?
>> FOX: So with our Geo--with both our forward
and our reverse Geo coder, our terms and service
say that the results must eventually be used
with the map. So you can't use a reverse Geo
coder if you're never going to display the
results on the map. So the thing is, when
you display the results in the map, we have
the attribution on the map, so that takes
care of it.
>> MARKS: Specifically on our Google Map.
>> FOX: Yeah, the Google Map, yeah.
>> But are you also allowed to store more
database and use them in other purposes as
long as you also display them on the map?
>> FOX: For other purposes? That gets a bit
trickier. What other purposes?
>> Well, that might be historic record of
places that somebody has been used to for
instance.
>> FOX: Ah.
>> MARKS: As long as those places will then
be displayed on the map. All right?
>> FOX: Yeah. So that's been tricky. You can
talk with--Mickey has volunteered himself
to be spoken to. That's Mickey our--so I should
mention that basically like half our engineering
team is in the audience right now. So Mickey's
right there. He's the product manager. He
loves legal questions, terms of use, his favorite.
He's always like, "Man, we should just talk
about laws up all day."
>> MARKS: Yeah, that's true.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> MARK: He proposed the whole session on
it but, I mean, we have conference on it.
We turned him down.
>> Hi there. I brought my laptop because I
got three questions if that's all right?
>> FOX: Yeah.
>> The first one is, the Static Maps API,
any news or updates on the idea of having
polyline coding for the static maps?
>> FOX: Yeah, we're working on it.
>> Okay. The second one was that reverse geocoding,
is that--is there a REST interface for that
or is it all JavaScript?
>> FOX: Yep. It's just the same like a URL
pattern, but you would send a latitude, longitude
into certain address. So we upgraded the geocoding
documentation because it wasn't that clear
for awhile. So if you look at the documentation
now, you will see a whole... Basically, geocoding
service is a standalone now, although you
do need to use it with the map. But you see
a section here at reverse geocoding, you can
see the results.
>> Okay. The last one was, as far as the ad
monetization you were just talking about,
are there any plans to incorporate standard
IAB advertising sizes, like if you're going
to buy 250 for instance as the best monetized
ad unit that I've ever seen in my site. And
given that it just puts two there right now
I was thinking about, is there a way that
people are going to be able to tag image ads
into that slot that are thrown in by 250 as
opposed to just the two stat text ads?
>> FOX: So right now they're all text stamps.
We're not serving up any image ads. And we
did play it. We played around the sizes for
a bit, but we decided to just to go with the
simple one and two for now. I just say with
monetization, it's kind of, we're constantly
experimenting. So we've announced these two
things but we're--we keep experimenting with
other things as well, stuff like size and
different types of ads. I don't really see
us doing image ads any time soon, probably.
You'll never know. So monetization in maps,
it's a really interesting problem to figuring
out like what somebody looking at the map
is actually there for, right, because everyone
using the map is there for different reasons.
So, we're always experimenting, and we'll--I'm
sure we'll keep the map with different options
for you.
>> MARKS: We're also trying to keep--I'm sorry.
We're also trying to keep in mind both, you
know, the publisher's needs but also the user
experience. So, if we're serving image ads
on the map, it might block part of the map,
and that's a bad user experience. So there's
a lot of fun. We're going to it. John, were
you about to say something? If you want to
say it at the mike so that...
>> Just a comment about the [INDISTINCT]
>> FOX: Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FOX: So that's something to experiment
with, is like how can we do similar ads but
maybe not be as intrusive for some users.
That's something we keep working on.
>> I work on a close environment while using
the Enterprise server, the [INDISTINCT] Enterprise
server. My impression right now is that Google
Maps API that's involve for the, you know,
Enterprise servers are not as robust as for
the public Google Maps. Can you comment on
this and can you offer suggestions, because
we want to go to the vast applications, but,
you know, we can't use your public services
at this point?
>> MARKS: All right, the Enterprise server,
the development on that moves are on a little
bit more slowly because it's hard to deploy,
to redeploy changes as things are going. We
have to be really careful because it's, you
know, the server itself is a downloadable
application. We are going to have some Enterprise
people around at the conference. They might
be talking--do you know about that?
>> FOX: Yeah. So with the... Oh, Tory. Hi,
Tory.
>> MARKS: Oh, Tory. Sorry, I didn't see you.
>> FOX: Tory is the enterprise version of
me.
>> MARX: Yeah, so, go talk to Tory.
>> So, when someone searches for like a large
region on Google Maps, it knows where to zoom
it to. Like, if you typed in "Russia," it
would, like, show the whole of Russia.
>> FOX: Yeah.
>> But I didn't see a way that you can actually
get the bounding box on a region in the public
API. Is there any way that you can get that
information?
>> FOX: Yep. So, apparently, we--yeah, so
that's not in the docs. So, a few months ago
or six months ago, we started adding bounds
information to the Geo [INDISTINCT] applet,
and that's the recommended view port grounds.
>> Oh, it's just in the applet when you deal
with that?
>> FOX: Yeah, it is. I don't know if it's
in the darks. It's in the extended data for
the [INDISTINCT] applet extended.
>> And you get that with the JavaScript API?
>> FOX: Yep, you can. Just use the, because
there's one function that gives you the full
JSON, so just do the function and it gives
you the full JSON, and then you can parse
out the bounds from that JSON.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> MARX: And if you're using a [INDISTINCT]
network blank on maps or it can send back
the bounding box to the server, and then you
can decide what to return.
>> Yeah. I was curious what you thought, you
might think of an HTML 6 element for maps.
>> Yeah. So we just had work camp, and that
was one of the things we discussed at work
camp was there's a video element in HTML 5.
Why isn't there a map element? I think that's
a really good idea. And I actually couldn't--no,
here's the problem. There already is a map
element in HTML, image maps, so we're going
to have to come up... I was thinking we could
call it like Geomap or real map or something
like that. So I think that's a great idea
that it doesn't technically affect us. It
would probably mean--if there was a map element
in HTML, I would imagine that would mean each
browser would implement it themselves, each
browser would probably pick a provider or,
you know, maybe use the open data. And then
for--so that would be for people who wanted
really, really simple maps. I think it's a
great idea there, right? You say like maps,
center, equals this, equals this. Yeah?
>> But, you know, like could we--the image
element allows you to put your image into
it or, you know, whatever you decide, a video
element, same--same idea I guess. Right? So
maybe a map could have Google on the one hand,
and my OGC server on the other.
>> MARX: The model with the video element
is that you link to a particular video and
then the browser decides what application,
what plug-in to use to display it.
>> FOX: Yeah, so you could--you could visibly
have a map element or do a KML file. I could
see that. I don't know that it would go, because
I mean HTML target is the simplest case, so
I don't if that would go as far as like enabling
custom map types. So, I think that--so it
would be really I think cool for developers
if there's was an HTML 5 map element. But
I think that we'll always need the Maps APIs
in order to really do the full power.
>> Oh, yeah, absolutely. But, you know, you
can see something simple like, because HTML
is kind of meant to be simple for people to
just, like, cut and paste something.
>> FOX: Right. So there is WHATWG mailing
list, it accepts suggestions, and I think
we should email the suggestions to them.
>> All right.
>> FOX: Speak it out, make it happen.
>> I'm interested in doing something that
currently I think is not allowed by the license
agreement, which is to print maps onto thin
slices of dead trees, meaning, paper. People
here may not use that anymore, but I was sending
out invoices, and what I wanted to do was
create an invoice for a customer and on the
flipside have a map centered on their locations,
showing our locations nearby. In this case,
it was for a car-sharing application. And
that's not allowed right now, printing. Can
you comment on whether that will be?
>> So, we came out with this set of printing
permissions guidelines, which applies generally
to all of our Geo products, because people
ask a lot of screenshots and stuff. So this
maybe came out last year. And so printing
has actually, there's--it's gone a bit more
relaxed. So you can read through the rules.
But one of the basic ones is that if you're
doing less than 5000 copies that a screenshot
of the maps is okay. So that's a very simple
version of the rule. But if you look through
the guidelines, I think you'll see it's a
bit more permissive now.
>> If I wanted to do more than a screenshot,
meaning, a slightly high resolution version
for print, what would I do in terms of using
the API to get more bits for my high resolution
printer?
>> FOX: So right now the APIs are all designed
for the web. So, you'll see that the outfits
we have are JPEG, PNG, GIF, and they're all
resolutions designed for the web. So we have
not optimized the APIs to be printable. And
it's certainly a feature request that we could
consider as offering high resolution. But
I don't think it would be our immediate thing
that we want to do.
>> Yeah. That's the kind of thing that I would
be willing to pay some per thin slice of dead
tree for.
>> FOX: Okay. That's a good idea. Maybe we'll
charge you for it.
>> MARX: Some people use static maps because
there you--because there are images there
that tend to be...
>> FOX: Yeah. It's just the resolution.
>> MARX: Yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah. Well, what I've done is I've
tiled them up in, you know, larger sizes than
they should be and then squash them back down.
And that works, but it's really a hack.
>> FOX: Sshh.
>> Anyway, I'll be happy to pay for that.
Did you get that part?
>> MARX: Sorry, I didn't.
>> FOX: Yeah, yeah. You know, that's good.
That's a really great idea. We'll totally
charge you for it.
>> MARX: You can pay me. Just see me afterwards.
>> FOX: Five dollars. I'll give you 500 DPI.
One dollar for a hundred.
>> MARX: Okay, and we got time for a couple
more question.
>> FOX: Oh, there is [INDISTINCT] question.
Oh, so there are... Okay. So, will there be
a mobile version of your client APIs, Blackberries
[INDISTINCT], et cetera? So, with mobile,
there is--for iPhone, there is a framer called
Mapkit, so you can do Google Maps in your
native maps. For Android, there is an API
called MapView. So, you can embed that in
your apps. For the other ones, there's nothing
in particular. Our current story is to use
the Static Maps APIs since that's like kind
of the lowest common denominator in a browser
control windows. But there is an entire session
tomorrow about Maps API and mobile. And you
never know what they might talk about there,
so you should probably get out. And the other
question was, "Any plans to integrate zip
plus 4 data into Google Maps? Yahoo has done
it. Well, so should probably do everything
that Yahoo does because they're...
>> MARX: [INDISTINCT] Sorry. Are these on?
Are these on?
>> FOX: I think we've looked at it, but I
don't think we have any immediate plans for
that, no.
>> One thing about Zip [INDISTINCT].
>> FOX: That's true. Yes, so you answered
the question, because somebody asked about
that earlier. So, yeah, I guess there probably
isn't a great source of data for that right
now that's really complete. And I don't know
how many people know there's a plus 4. I don't
know mine. If it doesn't help me, then we
don't do it.
>> MARX: You're looking [INDISTINCT].
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FOX: Three hundred changes per month.
>> MARX: Okay. I think we have officially
run out of time. If you want, we will be in--you
can come up and ask us questions during the
transition. And also I'll be hanging out in
the office hours much of the day. There are
other talks. So, thanks a lot, everybody.